the american secretary of state landed
in doha for this key moment
maybe the beginning of the end of
decades of conflict in afghanistan
the qatari capital is the setting for
the talks a process of reconciliation
between afghanistan's warring factions
the taliban and representatives of the
afghan government
together we've come to this country to
achieve a dignified and lasting peace
with goodwill and good intention
to stop the 40 years of bloodshed and
achieve country-wide
lasting peace the mullahs whose number
had harbored al qaeda and osama bin
laden nearly 20 years ago
in the same room now as america's
secretary of state
and the afghan government who they have
fought for so long
the taliban's representative pledged
peace to the weary and skeptical
afghan people we want to give them this
assurance that with full honesty
we continue the afghan peace negotiation
and we will try for peace and
tranquility
we will pay for the ground in
afghanistan
there have been huge compromises to get
to this point including controversial
prisoner releases
until just a few days ago the taliban
were still demanding
that more of their fighters be released
we welcome the taliban commitment not to
host
international terrorist groups including
al qaeda
nor to allow them to use afghan
territory to train
recruit or to fund raise
we welcome the same commitments by the
government islamic republic
afghanistan that they should never
permit their nation to serve as a base
for international terrorists
to threaten other countries the
americans have already signed a separate
agreement with the taliban setting out a
timetable for u.s
forces to withdraw the many nations who
fought the taliban will now resist
or accept an uncomfortable feeling of
futility
for britain it was a war in which the
government infamously hoped that not a
shot would be fired
instead towns like sangin musa kala
kajaki became synonymous with hard
battles
and many lives lost 15 years on these
places are all now back in taliban
control
[Music]
now they are pledging peace but in a
country that's been a battleground for
centuries not decades
it'll be hard to find mark stone sky
news